it goes sideways you can see it in
people's faces you can hear in their
voice you can see it in their body
language and you know inside they get
upset
well you have a great look because you
could be so many things but you could
definitely play out of West Texas
absolutely and so probably could yeah
do do you have different looks on your
on your you know just for your website
and different things where you just try
to play it more Anglo or whatever or
plot try to be more Mediterranean that's
a great question you know I have
necessarily played different characters
who looked at different way but in
coming back to you know you don't want
to work and you want to be successful
and you want to continue that path what
ended up being my bread and butter were
I call it suit man because I this this
is new the hair and not sure I'm having
a beer well thank you women love it guys
not so much okay it's interesting it's
been a very interesting the past couple
of years now I've grown my hair out to
see the reaction and stuff and and it's
kind of been I say this a you know like
it's a career suicide am I out of my
effing mind to do this because I was
always clean shaven short hair I look at
pictures of myself I'm like oh my god
who is that who is that guy but that guy
worked all the time but it was a look
right mr. Morgan Stanley I mean totally
know I did or something no no no I did a
lot of financial institution has I did a
lot of billionaires yeah I can see that
technological you know luminary kind of
people doctors lawyers like these
authority figure people right and I
guess it's kind of my voice and my
energy and whatever got a dance with who
brung you right but there's a whole
other a splice I choked unless a you
know people haven't seen me in a while
like oh wow your hair
Mike yeah man this is who I am on the
inside I just let it come out yeah right
cuz it was funny thing what happened me
on sets you know I'd be on a set I have
this you know hair like comb back and
you know very clean-cut you know
probably racist definitely conservative
definitely you know whatever got to have
fun with it and then I would start
talking about the things I'm doing
later that week and people just kind of
go huh yeah they're like you know you
you don't talk anything like the way you
look and that sounds so obvious when you
hear it but I would just wouldn't think
about it because I got a job at hand I'd
go back and do the job and that'd be a
craft service table or it would be you
know on set between takes or whatever
and then later at night at home it will
usually at night you're laying in bed
like what what does that mean but it and
now I go back and look at the pictures
of myself I'm like oh my god yeah you
know okay that makes sense I wouldn't
expect that guy to talk like that either
yeah you know just a saying in this
business I stay saying but it's
something that's important to me and it
was a part of you know recovering from
being undermined control for all those
years and in a cult which is really just
an abusive relationship in a lot of ways
it's a lot more than that but that's
really what it is
so being of service to others who are
not as fortunate than me so just by the
nature of me having this white skin
right I have got an easier path in life
I just do and I'm a man and I'm a tall
man and you're very attractive oh well
thank you very much well that that so
those are things going in my favor
that I had nothing to do with that was
just the genetic lottery right that's
just the roll of dice so you know I'm
married to a woman who's a black woman
and grew up in a very unique situation
civil rights movement my father-in-law
and his best friend started the civil
rights movement so it gave me a whole
other perspective that I never looked at
before in life ever and I feel like in a
he'll for not noticing it because in my
family so my father's Iranian my
mother's American
well they're both Americans but you know
he came from Iran and they had four boys
first of all they eloped to get married
oh wow my mother still wants to fight me
on that that she didn't elope but I
don't know you tell me
if you get married okay and neither
family is excited
about the marriage okay like his family
had a wife picked out for him oh right
and he was raised Muslim can't stand
religion right thinks it's the scourge
of the earth my mother was raised as a
Mormon Oh
exactly yeah she didn't want to exact
what a family dinner that would be hang
on there's more but wait there's more
so they got married in Reno Nevada on
December 31st with none of the family
members there that's eloping am I wrong
I would imagine I would imagine right
right yeah those little chapels and
reaaargh I've been to Reno they have
some really interesting like these it's
a gambling yeah yeah it's Nevada Reno in
Vegas right so they were in Reno cuz
they were living in San Francisco at the
time where he was going to school up
there something like that anyway they
have four boys on the oldest of four
boys all three of my brothers were gay
right I'm the black sheep amazing right
and then on top of that we moved a lot
like every two and a half three years
was the new kid again new guy with this
really long Iranian name like it's a
proper Iranian name but I look like
Steve apple pie right that and so how
conflicting yeah and my last name is
beech Archie right Dixon is my middle
name my full first name is duration
DeRusha Dixon beech Archie there's a
mouthful but then I look like this so
there's a huge disconnect cognitive
dissonance every time a new kid and by
the way a B C D sighs either the first
or second kid called
every time oh gosh awesome and you're
the new guy and it's a funny name so
there was always that conversation right
yeah yeah it's the whole thing it's the
whole thing how do you reconcile that
being from sort of two different worlds
and maybe not even identifying with
either one just like I don't know I'm
assuming yeah oh you man you hit the
nail on the head
it's a lot it's so part of it is just
that's that's my life that's how I was
raised
that was the circles were the
circumstances of me of my life and then
as I've gotten older I start to realize
wow that's a lot that's a lot right like
your reaction just now three gay
brothers yeah three gay brother not one
three right out of four right in
a Mormon Iranian an American right
I had to elope even though mom doesn't
like that sorry mom
it is a lot and then on top of that Iran
became the axis of evil so it's in the
eyes of in the eyes of a lot America's
of America right which is a whole other
conversation I have by the way for
another time and then America by the
Iranians is called the Great Satan and
my friend Cyrus Copeland wrote a great
book about his father and we knew each
other growing up in Iran and it's a
great book off the radar I highly
recommend it but he says you know I have
the blood of the Great Satan and the
axis of evil flowing through my veins
and I was started to laugh I couldn't
stop laughing and I was like dude you
hit the nail on the head it's kind of
bananas and then but you know I live in
America I've lived most of my life in
this country you know all but about five
and a half years have been in this
country and I love Iran I love Europe
and not all Iranians hate Americans by
the way no they don't yeah that's okay
yeah that's something that our media has
definitely helped to portray sorry well
yeah no it's if they don't and you know
when my friend went to when Cyrus went
to Iran he was doing research on the
book he had an interaction or he burned
his foot in the sauna sauna I think so
he went to see the doctor at this hotel
that he was staying at and and he's like
oh you know you're bandaging you know
the leg of the Great Satan and any and
the doctor so as I look
there's a big difference between your
government and your people just is it a
big difference between my government and
my people and right now I'm treating a
person and you're talking to a person
and the government doesn't have anything
to do with this right yeah and that's a
wisdom that that's not just that that's
a very common place in Iran which is one
of the most educated populations in the
entire Middle East certainly in the
world they put up they place a premium
on education and they're one of the
oldest civilizations in our planet right
and there's a wisdom to that comment
like the government is the government
the people are the people and there are
two separate beings the government can
be saying one thing but the people have
a different feeling altogether so yeah
it's it's interesting it's it's it's
been challenging because since 1977 when
the rope or 79 when the revolution
occurred the Iranian Revolution which we
you know we escaped luckily by I mean
had the clothes on her back in suitcases
that was it it was it was not fun but we
got off a lot easier than a lot of
families did but since that time man you
know as soon as people find out I have
Iranian blood you know things go
sideways you know and it's always very
small it's just you know but it goes
sideways you can see it in people's
faces you can hear in their voice you
can see it in their body language and
you know inside they get upset that's
okay I was thinking of a book by
Flannery O'Connor and she wrote a lot
about you know racism in the south and
she talked to you that there was one
line where she said like I feel sorry
for people that are half because they
have it the hardest because I'm actually
she was reading it so I'm like imitating
her voice and that that is very
difficult when you are in you you're not
a hold of something in terms of being
accepted by both by by one side or
another and I think that's very
difficult for people when they're a
mixture of something in that sense I
know we're all mixtures of something but
because you're never it's almost like
you're not part of
the one side totally I don't know I'm
thinking of my own experience yeah I
don't you know it's it's it's
everybody's got their something right
like this is definitely you know again
I'm a white man in America in a first
world you know first world country white
man and I've got money in the bank I got
food in the fridge and a roof over my
head so what am I talking about however
you know the emotional world is a
different thing and then having to deal
with you know the social aspect the
fabric of wherever I am yeah it's you
know I still got choked up I stopped you
stopped it
it does man it bothers me it wears me up
and it gets and I'm white imagine if I
had darker skin right or maybe an even
bigger nose or thicker lips or nappy
hair right I don't know then what right
so I in a lot of ways what do I owe a my
to talk I can only speak about my
experience and hmm I don't know that's a
big question that's it's that's a lot
says a lot
I do feel Iranian and in so many ways it
was my first language my first sounds
the first music the first smells the
first food you know the first sites were
necessarily all in Iran they're all
Persian it's all that right and that's
deep deep deep inside me I remember when
we went to live in Iran I was about 12
years old and we went back and it was
like going back to a very familiar place
I'll necessarily call it home cuz you
know I was a kid and I thought America
was that's all I really knew consciously
but it was like the sound the rhythm the
cadence des smells the the beat you know
the groove of the whole thing was all
very familiar which was wonderful
yeah really wonderful in ways that I
can't really fully explain
and you don't get cast as an Iranian I
imagine III don't see it in you at all
never I see a guy that gave me from the
San Diego yeah like this they think I
would go your Beach guy your surfers
right but I've also seen photos of you
from from doing the research and you
could be ya the Morgan Stanley you know
guy that's on the 18th floor and it's
easy with the steeple you know hands and
you know got a guy on speakerphone and
it's like you know I did a lot of roles
like that a whole lot yeah yeah and it's
always the most fun you get to be the
obnoxious you know like the sure
that's just come on where else can you
act like that and get paid for it and
not get a rest and have people hate you
because they know you're just playing a
part
right but that must be interesting to
reconcile with that because then you're
also playing a role in that sense that
maybe fearful of actually who you really
are or where you came from
oh yes like you know we're doing I'm
sure yeah yeah yeah I've had to yeah
I've had to go that'd be that guy that
you know the short hair that you know
steeple hands the you know master of the
universe mr. suit man as I called it and
had to say some ugly words and act you
know less than favourably toward other
people and say some really some
ideologies that I don't share at all and
you know it's I can jump into that and
do it easily because I've heard it come
at me and I've heard it come at you know
my loved ones more often than I care to
mention but yeah it's it's a weird one
you know yeah Here I am I got this hair
growing out and I'm not playing suit men
anymore and I'm talking about trans and
media but it right and creating this
something you know a whole different
thing like a franchise type of a thing
which is like it's crazy big thinking
but you know what why not why not
because that guy I feel like that guy's
been played out he can always come back
man you can cut hair shave and throw a
suit and tie on and you
he's back you know you could do a
ponytail and slick it up and then just
you could study that I've done that too
yeah I could still be that guy with the
ponytail you can do all of these still
exist but you know the funny thing is as
I go into casting offices for the past
I don't know however long here now and
someone hasn't seen me you know they're
always like oh wow wow
and it's favorable it's a little
shocking but you know it's it's
interesting because now they realize
there's more to it to it than they first
thought right like you've got someone
pigeon-holed we always compartmentalize
go that's that's who Karen is okay yeah
all right that to Dar is right and it's
just interesting I didn't mean to do
this
it just happened it well I had a rough
summer two summers ago I had back pain
turned into back surgery in like 20 days
oh it was bad surgery once spectacularly
well pains gone the I had something
called foot drop so it was literally
nurse started to be any of nerve damage
all gone two weeks later I had
diverticulitis which I didn't even know
what the hell it was and and basically
they don't know what it is you get a
little bit of irritation in your colon
they don't know what causes it how it
occurs but I almost died from it yeah
not good and that got my attention that
got my attention I didn't like think oh
my god I almost died and make a big
thing out of it
my mother grew up I grew up with my
mother was an ER nurse for 30 years and
I see you for another 2 or 3 years on
top of that and she worked and managed
health care for man she worked and
managed health care for almost another
30 years after that maybe 20 years or
something like that so I grew up in
hospitals I was always at the hospital
you know we're gonna go see mom or I had
to go drop her off at work or go pick
her up as I started to drive and stuff
so I've always been around that type of
thing so I didn't like a lot of people
if they get it you know a sniffle or a
cough no disparagement that's the end of
the world they're dying oh do I have you
know right now like no take it easy
you're gonna be alright
[Music]
you